one by one they're hold off hard even to
spot the few solitary protesters for the
Sea of yellow press fests but the riot
police have their ways
we are not meet this woman shouts as
she's dragged to a police van not Cannon
prodder
most of those you see arrested here are
women because there is the risk if
you're a man that you'll be issued a
summons at the Detention Center there
have been numerous instances already
recorded of that so it's safer to come
out as a woman
social media from the regions suggests a
degree of Mayhem to this mobilization
effort a fight in ompsk when these men
try to make the police come with them to
the front
one man in this line tells the others
we're going to be meat as another asks
who will feed his family
these two men we meet in Moscow though
are happy to go if they have to foreign
people's Republic's Embassy in Moscow
people from Don bass cast their votes to
join Russia a foregone conclusion with
no Legal Foundation that will see Russia
Annex a huge swathe of Ukrainian
territory
this was Muslims
foreign
it's a
nothing is
this woman asks us to film her we say
the police will come and you're not
scared to do this
here I'm scared
but still it's very brave
it's better to be there done in this
world
dynamagne Sky News Moscow